you can't just put anybody in any scheme
and think oh well I'm just gonna make
him fit my scheme like you gotta like
it's almost like they didn't even watch
tape of him in in Seattle and say hey
okay this is what he likes to do this is
stuffy that's like saying hey I know Von
like to rush from this side all right
I'm not even gonna worry about where you
like to rush from or where is this
yeah I'm gonna put any more I'm gonna
use him how I'm gonna use him you know
what I mean and expect him to be
effective and then when he's not
effective be like what's wrong with that
like no it ain't what's wrong with Von
what's wrong with you Bond rushes from
here you rushing from here he's going to
be the bond you're expecting to be if
you have Russell Wilson run the plays
that he's run and had success with he
will be the guy you expecting to be but
when you run him have him run offense he
has not run in the 10 years he's played
expect him to to struggle until he
figures it out